[Applause]
hi how are you look at your studio
i am so jealous oh my gosh i also want
to congratulate you on another season of
the show
thank god i'm so relieved i mean people
don't realize
how hard it is how hard it is to start
something
anything to start something during a
pandemic without the plan that you had
sketched out for a year all of a sudden
it's totally different yep
and to succeed the way you've succeeded
is a huge tribute to you and your crew
thank you it's all about the crew it's a
big deal
we're all we've had and so it's a
testament to us
and i am saying this to the man who
truly knows
what making a show is all about and you
just celebrated i see all your family
and friends celebrating your
fifth anniversary yeah sunday today
thank you
yeah yeah it's uh like you we started it
five years ago not quite knowing where
it was heading
it was doing something a little bit
different within the today show family
and you know we tinkered with it along
the way the same way you have probably
and
i think we finally landed on something
that might stick around for a while
it's interesting when you are so kind of
gut convinced
that something's going to work and it
just totally totally
when i started that show so my other job
i was on the today show at the time
hosting the third hour
and morning joe on msnbc so i had these
two jobs and my plan was what if i
smash those two shows together and make
some combination of that
and it was a little too much of the
conversation off the top at the
beginning where
the audience needed to actually know
what was going on in the world and not
launch into the conversation the way we
do on morning joe so
that was part of the learning so we
walked that back a little bit we still
have our conversations of course but
by and large it's here's the news and
then we make the turn to it being kind
of a magazine show
well and we're going to do thank you for
doing the art of the interview which is
a digital series i do to pick the minds
of
you know uh people that i admire
especially in the journalistic
sense curious people people who have
figured out how to have
an art in the interview itself
what is something that
is advice i'm asking for myself here
what is advice to asking that surprising
question that might catch off guard
might be a bit
pushy but really is going to ultimately
bring
insight into that person we're not
getting otherwise
i think it starts with trust and i think
you're really good at that
actually which is that you are open
yourself
you're willing to share which you've
been on our show twice by the way
and it's a short list of the sun it's
you dolly eine garten there's like four
people and you're
you're in that company my goodness but
you i know
if i can build trust with you and you
know that number one i've
i'm well researched that i'm not
interested in whatever the gotcha
question
is from the gossip magazine that's just
not what i do
if you can start a conversation and
frankly on our show we have time you
know i sit with somebody as you know for
45 minutes or an hour
so even if i don't know the person i'm
building a rapport so once you have that
trust
you you might not even have to ask the
question they might just start sharing
something with you or talking about
you know i don't like to zero in on pain
in someone's life
but if i feel like we've got enough of a
relationship in the interview that
they're willing to go there
then i will or a lot of times as i say
it will just come out because we've
built that rapport over the course of
the interview
i definitely am someone who is
willing to go there myself and i would
like to
welcome um anyone else to go there with
me and
what you just said made me think of your
signature piece in your show the highs
and the lows
and i was wondering if i could turn that
question on to you
i love that and why don't we start with
the lows so we can end on the high oh
okay
all right i guess professionally um
as i think about it it's interesting
we've been celebrating five years of the
show and it's all been sort of the
glossy interviews and all the great
people we've talked to
but the lows are as i said it's still a
news show so a lot of times you'll wake
up on a sunday morning unfortunately and
something terrible has happened the
night before
and so in our first year of the show is
june of 2016 we're only two months into
it
and it was the pulse nightclub shooting
in orlando and i was on the air that
morning
i think for seven and a half hours alone
no commercials
just talking and trying to get everybody
up to speed and interviewing people
and i'll never forget the moment when
the police first
came out to the microphones and we're
trying to assess what exactly had
happened
and he said we have 50 casualties and
i'll never forget saying to my producer
off mike did he say 50 do you mean
5 did he say 15 which is bad enough did
he say 50 and they said yeah
he said 50. and then over the course of
that morning i'm
interviewing people who've just lived
through the worst thing you could ever
live through
i i can't sort of express to people
enough
what type of person
with an empathic heart a curious mind
and someone who is again incredibly well
versed in the ways of the world the
current news and humanity
in general to be able to go on the air
for seven hours
hear these stories tell these stories i
think you can really
feel the authenticity of someone i agree
all i've done for my whole career is
just be myself
just totally be myself and you can't
play tv or try to be the anchorman or
what would walter cronkite do right now
you just have to be you
okay the highs well let's end on the
highs before we go to commercial break
well for me it's the people you don't
hear from a lot when we land an
interview
with someone like that so al pacino was
one of them last year
i mean look at this picture work i am
cruising around beverly hills
in a drop top cadillac eldorado with al
pacino
and that is an out of body experience
yeah no that's a moment
so i sat down with him he doesn't do a
lot of interviews as i said
for about an hour we talked through his
career and he said he was turning 80 and
he felt like it was time and he was
ready to talk
and then he just agreed to everything
yeah we can do an hour and then we'll go
for a drive around beverly hills and all
these people are yelling at him he's
having a time of his life and i thought
what life is this you know how did i end
up in this car
with al pacino riding shotgun uh
homework
curiosity and being a good person
you know i mean that you use a ladder of
other people it just won't be there and
if you use a ladder of yourself
you will build slowly but there's a
strong foundation there